SUZIE: Dad, I need your help.
TODD: Why sure, Suzie,
what's on your mind?
SUZIE: I have two tickets to The
Wallabies concert this weekend,
and I don't know who to invite.
I was thinking maybe Laura
because she's new in town.
But Pamela's been my best
friend since forever,
except that she's been ignoring
me ever since she started
going steady with Johnny.
TODD: Well, here's the
thing about friendships.
Friendships are sort
of like gift baskets.
Each one has its own unique
set of, umm, OK look,
I was really kind of
hoping this was going
to be a CocoaPods question.
Do you have one of those for me?
SUZIE: You're not
a very good father.
TODD: I know.
But seriously,
CocoaPods, hit me.
SUZIE: Well, now
that you mention it,
I've been noticing
these Podfile.lockfiles
in my project.
What are those?
TODD: Ah, so this is a
question I can answer.
So don't let that
lock name confuse you.
It's not like there's another
CocoaPods process somewhere
that's editing a file somewhere.
See, a CocoaPods lockfile
is important in that it
keeps track of every
version of every library
that CocoaPods has
installed for you.
You can think of it as
something like a snapshot
of exactly what CocoaPods has
installed in your iOS project.
SUZIE: That doesn't
seem very important.
It really just sounds
like something that
would satisfy my curiosity.
TODD: Au contraire, sweetie.
See, a lockfile
is very important
if you're working
together with a team.
This will help you all make
sure that all of your files
are in sync.
SUZIE: Really?
How?
TODD: Let's say that you and
Mark are working on a project
together.
You two are still dating, right?
SUZIE: Yep.
TODD: You know how I
feel about boys who put
side effects in their getters.
SUZIE: I don't really care,
Dad, I love him anyway.
TODD: OK, you know what?
Let's watch this.
OK, so let's say you go ahead
and add a line like this
to your Podfile.
SUZIE: Hey, that's the Twitter
walker from the last video.
TODD: Aw, you watched.
Now shut up, I'm talking.
Now you run pod install.
Now let's assume
the latest version
of our hypothetical
library is 1.3.3,
so you'll get that version
added to your project.
Now let's say a few days later,
the author of the library
updates it to version 1.4.
You don't run pod update, so
you're still happily plugging
away on version 1.3.3.
But now let's say Mark
gets a copy of your project
and he runs pod install.
Well, without that
lockfile around,
CocoaPods would just
go out and install
version 1.4 on his machine.
If he starts using features
that aren't in version 1.3.3,
it could break your code when
you merge in his changes.
SUZIE: Dad, how does
a lockfile help?
TODD: I'm getting
to that, be patient.
Now on the other hand, if you
have your lockfile checked
into your project, it'll
record what version
you have installed.
Then when Mark runs pod install,
even though version 1.4 is
out there, CocoaPods
will see that-- according
to your lockfile-- your
project should only
have version 1.3.3
installed, and so that's
what it'll install for Mark.
Now granted, if Mark--
being the irresponsible boy
he is who doesn't take
the proper precautions--
goes out and runs pod
update without telling you,
well then, yes, CocoaPods will
go out and grab version 1.4.
But because that change is
also reflected in the lockfile,
that will get merged in as well
when you merge in Mark's code.
So at least you'll be aware
that something's changed.
Oh, another nice
feature of the lockfile
is that if you're tracking
it in source control,
you've got a very nice
snapshot of every library
you've installed
at any given time.
So if things suddenly break, you
can use it to jump back in time
and recreate the exact
environment you had when
you checked in the log file.
SUZIE: That does seem useful.
Say, as long as we're
talking about source control,
do you think that I should
put my pod directory inside
of my source repository
of my project?
TODD: Well, there's two
schools of thought on that.
One school of
thought essentially
looks at your pod
directory as derived data.
As long as you have both your
Podfile and your lockfile
checked into your project--
and you should-- then
anybody could, in theory,
recreate that environment
at any time just by
running pod install.
SUZIE: Sure, but what if you
don't have CocoaPods installed?
TODD: Well, that's where
the other school of thought
comes in.
They believe that because
your pods directory contains
essential files needed
to run your project,
you should absolutely
check it in.
That way, anybody could
download your entire repository
and run it, no other
steps required.
SUZIE: Yeah, although that
seems like it might cause
your repository to get bloated.
TODD: Well that's probably
true, but hard drive space
is cheap these days.
Maybe a bigger concern
might be if you end up
with merge conflicts
in your pod directory,
I could see that being
troublesome to fix.
SUZIE: So what should I do?
TODD: Well, that's
really up to you.
The CocoaPods folks
generally recommend
checking in your pods
directory, but as long
as you and the rest of your
team agree on the same practice,
you should be OK.
SUZIE: No, no, Dad.
I meant what should I do
about The Wallabies concert?
I still don't know
who to go with.
TODD: Oh, that's easy.
Go with the more
popular one, duh.
SUZIE: Dad, you're
so stuck in the '50s.